[Musique]
on peut être roi de père en fils chez
les ackermann cependant ce n'est pas une
couronne que l'on se transmet mais un
simple képi celui que porte tous les
traminots employés à la compagnie des
transports strasbourgeois
voici albert ackermann il a 36 ans et
occupe un poste de receveur sur la ligne
2 32 il est employé à la cts depuis
l'âge de 14 ans pas surprenante alors
qu'il en fût bien longtemps le bain
j'aime ici son père joseph presque 60
ans est tout près de la retraite ancien
wattman il est receveur de bus sur la
ligne 4 14 bon pied bon oeil quoiqu'un
peu dur d'oreille jacques ackermann n'a
plus l'âge de porter le képi ou la
casquette à un béret c'est nettement
mieux à ce nonagénaire
jacques est le père de joseph et le
grand père d'albert par conséquent il
est né en 1870 et de ce fait vécu le
plus souvent sous le régime allemand il
y a quelques jours ont fêté le 95e
anniversaire du doyen des conducteurs de
la cts grand père comment vous êtes vous
décidé un jour à travailler au tramway
strasbourgeois
[Musique]
c'était le 23 juillet 1899
j'avais 29 ans 29 ans passés à la maison
pourquoi autres parce que je ne gagnais
pas le sou son premier emploi au tramway
laveurs de voitures des histoires ce bon
vieillard pourrait en raconter des
ordures en à son interlocuteur trente et
une années passées à la cts jacques
karman se souvient encore des voitures
sur rail que précédait le bon cheval de
trait
bien avant 1900 apparurent les premières
rames électriques leur aspect diffèrent
bien de celles que vous avez connues il
ya quelques années encore pour que la
cabine du walkman soient protégés et non
plus ouverte à tous les vents grand père
jacques l'on aperçoit ici à gauche se
souvient d'ailleurs que tous les
traminots avait alors décidé un
mouvement de grève le tramway modifié
avantageusement sa ligne alors que la
serrure bn strasbourg reuters heim avait
à sa tête une motrice à vapeur ironie du
sort c'est le 1er mai 1960 que le bus
prenait la succession du bon vieux
tramway dont il était très difficile de
se séparer
ce fut au milieu d'une foule nombreuse
et bruyante quoiqu'un peu attristé
milieu d'imposantes funérailles
on n'oubliera pas ce jour là de faire
appel aux doyens de la cts jacques
ackermann
à 90 ans il conduisit son bon vieux
trams à sa dernière demeure le premier
des 60 et grand père jacques
vous avez eu mal au coeur j'ai pleuré
tout simplement si c'était à refaire
aujourd'hui choisiriez à nouveau les
transports
oui si j'étais jeune je retournerai au
tramway
je gagnais m'enfin je ne vais pas en
faire davantage
comment jacques ackermann utile pu nous
apporter une autre réponse ils
n'hésitent pas parfois à se rendre au
dépôt tout proche de neudorf lui qui
autrefois procéder au lavage des
premiers wagons semble rêver devant la
modernisation sans trame jacques
ackermann l'emportera au paradis mais
nous n'en sommes pas encore là aussi
contentons nous de lui souhaiter tout
simplement un bon anniversaire
[Musique]